when did this first start where nick
started to get sick and you and we won't
we won't go through it entirely but like
we'll skip over some things but like you
know i'm sure
you're thinking this is not a big deal
in the beginning correct like this is a
young guy you never had you explained
yeah oh yeah i mean it was it was weird
nick i think was a bit of a
hypochondriac with sickness so
he was saying from day one i have used i
have this thing i have this thing this
is what he kept saying and because his
only symptom was that he was tired i was
like no you don't and it all started on
my birthday night
and um and then you know for the next
two weeks he basically just slept all
day every day but
yeah i was not worried about it because
i was like this isn't a symptom of cobit
so
you definitely don't have povet you can
smell you can taste you don't have a
fever you're not coughing
you're just tired i thought he was
depressed which nick could easily go
into uh you know because he's he's a
performer he's a musician
and everything in that world just got
you know in all of our worlds
especially that
so um yeah i didn't think anything of it
and when did you realize this this is
something i didn't get extremely worried
until um like the night before we i took
him to the emergency room
um that would have been march 29th and
um i got worried because his breathing
was really bad for the first time i was
like
you can't breathe like you're having a
hard time like walking from the kitchen
table to the sofa which is like
12 feet like
what's you know that's when i got scared
right and when even when i took him to
the emergency room i was like i'll pick
you up in two hours i was like i i
literally was like i'll just not walk
around third street with all this i'll
pick you up in a couple hours and so
what do they say they they
he's in the emergency rooms doctor calls
you or calls you in no no they call you
they call you you can't go anywhere so
they call you and what do they say nick
called me the doctor didn't even call me
nick called me and he said amanda they
want to keep me overnight they're gonna
they put me on some oxygen to help me
with their breathing they want to do
some further tests they're testing me
for covet and they're keeping me here
overnight just to make sure i'm okay and
i was like oh okay gosh all right well
i'll talk to you tomorrow again not
being like
i don't and he had no real pre-existing
conditions nothing i mean it's just he
was never sick nick never was sick he
was like if he had a cold it was like
wow you have a cold i mean he was like
never sick so jump ahead
when you realize this is this is really
serious and i can't believe i'm going
through this
i didn't think it was really serious
until the day um
that they called and told me that he
died on the table for two minutes
because and i'll say that because the
the ten days leading up to that when he
was in the icu even though the icu was
scary
every day
i was getting reports back from next
doctor that he's doing great
we're pro we're progress and progress
every day
numbers are looking great we'll take him
off the ventilator on you know thursday
he'll be home by the next wednesday like
doing great amanda everything's great
and so i was like okay
so i was you know
hanging out with elvis trying to like be
the best single parent i could be
and uh managing everything at home
trying to manage my fitness business
because that was the only thing that was
making money for us at the time
so i was just like you know great he'll
be home by wednesday and
boy this this has been crazy you know
but wow so they just keep throwing kind
of false hope at you kind of well or
maybe not even false hope they're
throwing things at you that this is
going to be okay that was the truth he
was progressing everything was going
great he was gonna get off the
ventilator everything was literally like
if it was on the incline of like
we're gonna he's gonna be completely
fine
and then they called the morning um uh
of april 10th and said you know
the exact opposite that overnight he
spiked a fever
his heart stopped
he went into septic shock and he's on an
hour like a minute to minute basis and
every hour counts
we'll let you know and i was like
that's when i was like what you know i
just got like chills like it's just
i'm shocked and i know the story i mean
i know what ends up happening
but it's it's absolutely got to be the
most shocking thing to ever hear when
you think okay
my husband's going to be back and things
are getting better and then all of a
sudden hey this is this is life and this
is what just happened